boucar diouf bonjour plus philippe
bonjour à pois et merci merci pour
l'invitation et moi je m'appelle boucar
diouf et voici mon frère et ils sont
nombreux à se souvenir de l'émission des
kiwis dm oui que tu as coanimé avec
francis reddy pourrait qui s'appelle
maintenant des malaises à londres royal
parce que c'est juste ça qui est resté
de l'émission voir et même hausser à
l'ogc nice et le goff j'ai jamais vu ça
de ma vie
on a fait mystère l'émission prendra
sept ans avec francis quelque chose que
800 émission d'une heure et demie est
tout ce qui reste c'est 10 minutes deux
minutes avec monsieur tri avec cette
espèce de bisous de marina moi je sais
tu es car à mon sens pas encore ah non
mais cote
non je suis devenu ça les gens te voient
puis tout de suite tu te dis salut la
palourde royale c'est vraiment ça la en
2018 a gâché ma vie ce mollusque ce
mollusque a gâché ma vie lui faire
crédit ou la mort à briser votre ami
finale alors francis était quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup alors on est on est
encore ensemble on se voit souvent
parlée par seulement ton grand père oui
est ce qu'il existe vraiment et ils plus
grand que nature
qu'est-ce qui y a
c'est une bonne question ça oui mon
grand-père exister parce qu'ils aient
décidé maintenant vraiment est-ce qu'il
est plus grand que nature oui je n'ai
embellie beaucoup mon grand père mon
grand père disait si l'arbre savez ce
que lui réserve la il ne lui aurait pas
fourni le match parce que je pense que
s'il était aussi extraordinaire que je
le raconte ne s'appellerait pas
seulement diouf
peut-être qu'ils ont le plus réduit à la
place mais c'est ça c'est un composite
mon grand père c'est un c'est j'ai
rassemblé dans un grand-père archétypes
tous les gens qui ont influencé
m'asseoir de verbes et ça comprend des
gens que j'ai côtoyés ici au québec
oscille entre et quand j'écris des
choses que je n'assume pas entendre ça
c'est plus simple pour moi de mettre ça
dans la bouche de mon grand père et je
les assume bien plus comme ça donc c'est
un grand père idéal que je me suis forgé
à partir de mon grand-père qui existent
mais qui était loin d'être parfait en
fait si tu te passe trop petit pour
changer le jour essaient de dormir dans
une tente avec un poster c'est le dalaï
lama qui disait c'est pas mon grand père
mon grand père était plus poétique que
sa lente et spectacles il ya beaucoup du
québec évidemment oui il est arrivé ici
en 1991
oui aussi de l'afrique d'une certaine
façon oui c'est un mélange des deux qui
se retourne souvent l'afrique oui ah oui
je retourne trois fois par année dès
fois parce que mes parents sont vieux
maintenant et je retourne souvent
j'amène mes enfants aussi
j'avais ma blonde on blonde aurait connu
ici mais avant d'aller plus loin je suis
allé avec elle en afrique puis j'ai dit
à ma mère tient une fille de matane ne
savais pas à quoi m'attendre ai dit ma
mère de la vie évoluée paiement des
beaux arts qui a trouvé une fois la
hauteur
[Applaudissements]
cette façon de me dit tu as trouvé ta
trouvé ton double que tu cherches et
puis donc j'amène des enfants pour
qu'ils s'en prennent aussi de cette
culture qui les appartient mais ce sera
deux décidé de l'adopter ou non parce
qu'ils sont nés ici un moyeu toute une
différence entre l'afrique et l'amérique
est ce que soit encore un peu ce mal de
vivre lorsqu'il survient au québec de
laisser derrière toi quelques
instruments ça c'est le drame de tous
les immigrés je pense c'est tout on
souffre qui te disais qu'il faut qu'il
revienne revient nous voir car c'est
c'est un à l'avant d'un monde - je viens
de ses rêves du sénégal on enterrait le
placenta qui le lit de la maman creusé
puis on enterrait le placenta et nos
anciens nous disait ou que tu puisses
être sur la planète
en vieillissant ton placenta va taper il
va diriger mouvoir tout cas j'ai besoin
de toi qui sent le sens là - jeu je le
sens c'est très puissant donc l'appel 10
aces et callum voir moustiques se poser
sur son testicule qu'elle comprend afin
que tous les problèmes de la terre ne
peuvent se régler par la violence
en terminant boucar diouf c'est bientôt
la première médiatique de son nouveau
spectacle oui à montréal et à québec au
mois d'avril
oui comment tout ça ben je me sens je
pense que je suis prêt je suis prêt
parce que je travaille beaucoup beaucoup
en amont
moi je me fixe trois objectifs quand des
clients spectacle zed il faut que ça
dilate la rate
c'est le premier critère il faut que ça
touche le coeur et si ça stimule
l'esprit ça c'est juste un bonus mais je
pense que les toits critères sont pas
mal réunis dans le spectacle puis ça va
être un voyage agréable pour les gens
qui vont venir loi de quoi boucar diouf
merci beaucoup s'est inversée